my first guest of course the talented
actor who has starred in numerous films
including rogue one a Star Wars story
milk and eat - mama tambien
please welcome Mexico City's own
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here what
made a few for being here when we
announced that we were coming to Mexico
City you immediately said I'm in and
we're very grateful no I am very happy
you're doing this this means a lot to
all of us obviously yeah how do you
think I mean you know you saw that I
tried to be in the telling what I was
laughing around there I mean it's
ridiculous you what's the problem
okay because you've been getting a lot
of Mexican women's attention I can smell
your urgency you know the problem with
the Mexican women sense that I'm too
needy is that yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
pretty obvious you know you know what
about this is this hurting me or helping
me in that that's hurting you badly
you're huge clearly you're huge a guy
the size of two Mexicans put together
yes you know and you don't have to add
another half a meter of him it's like so
pretentious like oh I have this okay oh
yeah he's hard all day long so you think
I could if I change the hair and relax
yeah
yes go ahead go for it go for it
oh yeah I know now I just looked drunk
don't have that Elam I'm gonna get you
drunk
Oh what is this I brought the medicine
for your urgent it's gonna make it -
that's a mezcal this is a mezcal it
didn't break the big bottle but that's
the size I used to when I'm nervous to
go into your show or now before the the
PTA meeting at the school of my kids
now I want to ask you Diego this is
fascinating to me
you've got your start in in telenovelas
and you began telling of those who
actually had sex on film before you had
your good yes you're going to I I
did I did I did you know you know if you
probably when you when you go like when
was the first time I had sex you have to
remember you go to this memory I can
just rent a film you know exactly when
it happened yes I know exactly it was
this amazing actress beautiful and I was
dreaming about it you know and and I
felt the luckiest I was 12 years old Wow
yeah you got a sex scene when you were
oh yeah I arrived and I was very nervous
and I was just like well I hope she
likes it then and after the scene
because I know it's not gonna be sex but
then something can start from there
right yeah and and then I get there and
they I see 40 people looking at me you
know night with the camera cameras yeah
everything like you just think of
like I don't want to have a heart please
please please I'm gonna get too excited
you know yeah and and obviously it
didn't happen I was 12 I couldn't
control it
she was very nice
she hated care of you that's important
here but I started doing telenovelas you
know yeah you start doing telenovela so
it was your training and then of course
what's happened to you since then has
been absolutely spectacular loved one a
Star Wars story significant I mean my
biggest biggest film in the world and
such a big deal for a Latino to be a
lead in a Star Wars movie this was a
seismic change it meant a lot and it
meant a lot for I mean today in this
time this is happening you know it's not
a coincidence you know I read I read
many things and there was a beautiful
beautiful thing that a girl from San
Diego wrote about the experience of
having her her father watching the film
and how the father reacted to my
character and the accent and feeling
represented on the screen so the father
of course the father was a immigrant and
he saw and he couldn't believe he
couldn't believe that he was watching a
Star Wars film and that his accent was
represented and that that he knew who I
was and the kind of medicine we're
talking about in these times you know we
need that medicine we need that medicine
I have obviously were doing a lot of
comedy here but on a personal level I've
talked to many many Mexicans since I
arrived and this is the biggest feeling
that I get from them they misunderstood
and their feelings are hurt on a very
simple human level specific politics
aside they've heard these things that
were said at campaign rallies they've
heard this chant build the wall they've
heard certain words used about them and
I've spent a lot of time trying to
explain to them many people in the
United States love the Mexican people
this is a misrepresentation of how
people feel
I agree and I think those people that
are afraid of being deported today their
voice has been silent and we have to
make sure their stories are told in and
out the states and that they get their
stories matter to us you know because
they need that strength to keep going
and ignorance we can fight with love and
and with understanding and and with
things like what you're doing you know
we wanted this to be a very positive
experience and what's the most beautiful
thing for me is you came and you asked
to produce her please I want laughter
listen please okay yes okay okay
numero uno sex okay numero dos was to
bring positivity
[Laughter]
of Mexico and and and let them know that
we that we hear them that we hear them
that they are heard and that what it's
so nice is that so many of them when
they've had an opportunity to speak I
don't get a lot of anger from them I get
them talking in a very beautiful
eloquent way saying we need to come
together we're really it's about it it's
a minute it's example thing which makes
me feel happy well I say we end because
we end on a positive note which is we
drink and I am an optimist and I think
better times are coming so Viva Mexico
[Applause]
Digital HD and blu-ray on March 24th BAE
you